money-wise yeah please do sing my songs
at karaoke but i don't recommend uh
like singing my songs at karaoke because
of the
sort of level i mean if you're having a
hard time singing them i don't know how
some people
how us yeah right peasant normies are
gonna be able to sing
personally would it's like you know when
you get like two drinks in you're like
yeah i think i can do eminem and then
you do it and you're like i
i don't remember this many lyrics where
were all these i thought it was just
slim shady standard
it's not just eminem it's like the
really long like four
versus eminem seven minutes long
i thought it was three alternatively
where you sing you you choose a song
and you think you know the lyrics and
you then you realize you only know about
two sentences from the chorus
and then there's just this awkward one
minute where you're just kind of like
humming along to the verse
is it annoying being a singer and then
having to go to karaoke because they
expect you to like kill everything
instead of just you know just
shouting i does i have a secret i sang
my own songs at karaoke
and um you know they have a really
uh weird system where they like the midi
soundtracks
no no they have this weird system where
they like to give you a score of how
good you see um
like when charlie chaplin entered like a
charlie chaplin and look-alike contest
they came in
third yeah yeah that's like the
equivalent like
like the points where they score you are
really
are very distinct and i tend to like
um do arrangements and do weird like
stuff with my songs so i don't sing it
exactly like i did at the studio yeah
so that automatically like
those those games do like the pitch it's
truly off pitch right yeah so it's just
like you could just go
i'm a bad singer so i i've never scored
well on any of those kinds of karaoke
games well i turn it off i don't want it
on
i don't know how bad i am at seeing it's
very bad have you ever been in the group
who
hasn't known that you were a singer or
and then you just start singing your own
song
and they're like wait a minute you sound
just like that person singing
sing the song
actually ever since i uh you know made a
debut i haven't been to karaoke because
it became
singing became my career wow it's it's
difficult to
do it for fun now yeah so it's i mean
it's just work for you and
it's and when i started singing i
automatically feel like i'm on stage so
i
i think that's a little bit heavy for
the karaoke goers
so i thought we were having fun having a
private concert right here
yeah that's that's a little bit of a
flex right going to a karaoke and
singing your own songs that's it that's
that's a bit of a place
then i usually am the one like just uh
putting everyone's um
songs into the machine yeah i love doing
the tambourine
i guess though it would be such a weird
pressure to go to karaoke with you
you absolutely kill your songs and be
like oh [ __ ] now i got to do sexy back
just the difference